happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday
[Music]
make way for the princess who has
arrived at her castle
i'm beautiful
oh yeah girl over the weekend cardi b
and offset gave their baby girl culture
a lavish princess inspired 3rd birthday
party
which included an animal farm real life
disney princesses
oh snap what is that is that a crab like
towel
and a crab leg tower which cardi was
super
excited about wow
culture even got to enjoy some fun in a
ball pin
but when she ended up face down it did
freak her mom out a bit
oh god oh somebody rescued my daughter
check out this cute moment when a
culture was dancing with her dad
offset but couldn't help but get
distracted by her beautiful cake
here is a better look at the edible
masterpiece which is a combination of a
carriage and a castle
[Music]
the princess also got to dance with her
mom before a very pregnant cardian
offset
took to the dance floor for some quality
time of their own
and boy did they get it in
culture wasn't too happy about that
balloon flying off
but the birthday girl managed to get it
back and her smile returned
[Music]
[Applause]
the next morning cardi and offset were
off to an appointment
to take a look at their new bundle of
joy i'm about to see
first think about
yeah yeah
cardi revealed that she and her hubby
offset are expecting their second child
together during her performance at the
bet awards
at the same time as the reveal cardi
shared this stunning maternity photo on
instagram
and wrote simply quote number two with a
heart emoji and tagging her husband
offset
that's some big big things on the way
big bangs cardi also shared this photo
which includes culture
in the caption she predicted what kind
of big sister culture would be
pointing out that her firstborn will
have the same age difference as cardi
and her younger sister hennessy
she wrote quote i just know these two
will love each other so much
and argue so much since they're three
years apart
just like me and honey but one thing for
sure is that they'll have each other's
back like no one else ever will
i don't know i just get too emotional
and come to my kids
in 2019 cardi opened up to e.t about how
she navigates both stardom
and motherhood as your career gets
bigger and bigger
how are you feeling about stardom is it
everything that you
thought it was going to be is it harder
better it's
definitely harder like the more money
the more problems the more people
um that that things they know you
and their opinions it just get harder
people don't understand
some people don't understand the
struggle some people don't understand
the work that i put in so they would
just always try to think that it came
easy for me how are you balancing
everything and are you experiencing that
mom's guilt a little bit
i do experience that mom guilt you know
because it's like oh my gosh oh they're
traveling i know her sleeping schedule
is getting a little messed up
and i know every single time that she
get on an airplane
it's all good and to the landing she
starts crying and i just be feeling so
sad because it's like i know the pain
you know when your ears pop
i just be so sad and like sometimes i
wake up in the morning
and like she's in my bed and i just want
to cuddle with
[Music]
totally